hi in this video I will talk about EPS B
and M EPS be so EPS B stands for excited
to repost in active potential and Mbps P
stands for miniature excitatory
postsynaptic potential so as we can
understand from the name that both of
the term suggests some post synaptic
activity now let us try to understand
using a neuronal diagram so here is an
Iran and there are at least four input
in this neuron and we focus on the input
a in and in this set up we can stimulate
the presynaptic and we can record from
the post synapse the neuron in blue now
once we inject a current in the prison
apps we see in the postsynaptic neuron
there is a change in potential and it is
in order of several 40 to 50 millivolts
and this change in potential is known as
postsynaptic potential and this kind of
course in the active potential has been
seen that it can give rise to post
synaptic spikes or post synaptic action
potential action potential in the
postsynaptic neuron so that's why it is
known as excitatory postsynaptic
potential because it can give rise to
action potential in the postsynaptic
neuron now what happens when a
presynaptic stimulation occurs there are
neurotransmitter the presynaptic action
potential reaches a synaptic terminal
and it releases neurotransmitter and the
neurotransmitter binds to the
postsynaptic ligand gated channels and
allow scattered influx the scattered
influx make the postsynaptic membrane
more positive and thereby a voltage
change and that voltage change is
recorded as a postsynaptic potential in
order of several Minah folds now here
are a few properties of the epsp the
excitatory postsynaptic potential might
give rise to action potential in the
it depends on the epsp strength whether
it can give rise to action potential or
not which I would be discussion
discussing shortly now the change in
potential is caused due to an influx
throughout to ligand gated ion channels
and also epsps our credit potential so
it doesn't have a fixed value it is not
a all-or-none phenomena so it's value
could be credit that means depending
upon the stimulus strength the values or
the change in potential could be
different so that is why it is known as
credit potential so now what is actually
downstream to epsp so what happens after
a epsp so when we stimulate the
presynaptic site or postsynaptic
potential in the synapse and that
depolarization wave which is generated
in the post synapse would actually flow
down towards the axonal initiation
segment there it can give rise to action
potential if the stem the if the
stimulus is strong enough or it might
not give action potential if the
stimulus is weak for example in this
case the stimulus is not strong enough
to elicit an action potential
whereas we when we inject a high of
current pulse depicted here by the
broken lines which is bigger which which
elicited a bigger response in the
postsynaptic neuron and it gives rise to
action potential in the postsynaptic
neuron now instead of giving a strong
current pulse if we give multiple weak
current pulse then also there is a
probability that action potential could
be generated because he PSPs can add up
one another and that could lead the
neuron to fire an action potential small
amount of voltage change could be
additive and it would make the membrane
potential towards more positive site
more depolarizing site and once it
crossed the voltage threshold it would
fire an action potential so he PSP
can give rise to action potential
depending upon the strength or even if
weak stimulus are there depending upon
the time course of the stimulus it can
give rise to action potential or not now
apart from epsp another type of
potential could be recorded from the
neuron let's say this in Iran is not
stimulated we are not using any
stimulating electrode to stimulate this
blue neuron and we put a sodium channel
and agonist known as TTX to block the
spike so the spontaneous activity of the
blue neuron is gone and as well as we
are not stimulating it in this situation
if we record from the poor synapse it
has been seen that still there are small
amount of responses in order of 1
millivolt could be recorded and these
are known as miniature excitatory
postsynaptic potential in 1952 Barnard
Kurds first seen this phenomena and
named these things as MEP SP or simply
the minis now what are actually minis
minis or mep SP is actually due to
spontaneous release of the
neurotransmitter vesicles and when we
are talking about mep sp1 important term
is Quantrell size-12 science means the
response elicited by the content of one
quanta
in very simple words quantal size means
response elicited by the content of one
neurotransmitter mediated vesicles so
let's say one liver Hospital mediated
basically is released and that give rise
to a small change that is actually ma PS
be an increase in quantum size would
simply mean more neurotransmitter is
inside the vesicle or more receptor in
the post synapse both of which can
increase eye amplitude of any PSP now
what is the relation between MA PSP and
epsp so people think that epsp is that
some of multiple MEP SP and this
hypothesis is known as one two
hypothesis as proposed by Bernard cards
in 1952 so where he proposed that
neurotransmitters are released in form
of small packets and small packets
actually one of these one of the small
packets would give rise to the MEP SB
and it has as a whole release of all the
neurotransmitter when our action
potential reaches the North Terminal
would give rise to epsp now MEP SB is
due to spontaneous release
whereas epsp is due to he [ __ ] release
when a stimulus comes then only epsp
kind of phenomena happens or otherwise
there is always there is a spontaneous
release the read out for spontaneous
release is M epsp I hope you like this
video I would talk about spontaneous
release and evoke release in detail in
my subsequent videos thanks for watching
please like subscribe and share thank
you